l'origine du monde de gustave courbet
une peinture associé au scandale
retour sur quelques polémiques 1982 art
press la revue référence dans le monde
de l'art contemporain choisi l'oeuvre
sulfureuse de courber pour sa une
et devinez quoi scandale évidemment
puisque en belgique
le distributeur du du numéro refuse de
distribuer et ça va beaucoup plus loin
puisque nos paquets d'art press
eh bien on en fait un autodafé c'est à
dire qu'ils sont brûlés commencé sous
l'inquisition où comme faisaient les
nazis une censure qui n'arrêtera pas
l'écrivain jacques henric en 1994 il
choisit une nouvelle fois l'origine du
monde pour la couverture d'un de ses
livres
une audace qui lui vaudra d'être banni
de certaines devantures de librairies
comme ici à besançon quelques âmes bien
pensantes ont donc été choqué après une
dizaine de plants à la mairie la
maréchaussée est intervenu pour
l'instant la fère s'est arrêté là mais à
clermont ferrand les livres ont été
purement et simplement retirés de la
vitrine en 1995 le tableau jusqu'ici
propriété de collectionneurs privés sans
escale au musée d'orsay à paris
l'oeuvre est désormais visible par tous
et là encore les avis divergent
non non rien rien de dégoûtant là dedans
qu'elle fascine ou qu'elles dérangent
les visiteurs se succèdent devant
l'oeuvre de courbet mais les polémiques
persiste en 1997 une troupe de théâtre
utilise l'origine du monde pour la
cuisse de son spectacle une idée qui
encore une fois ne plaît pas à tout le
monde
la dèche en échec une provocation dans
les gènes opus on n'est pas sa sueur aux
murs ont été négligents plus même
accueil en 2001 pour les affiches d'une
compagnie de théâtre de belfort pour
pouvoir faire leur promo l'oeuvre de
courbet doit être caché sous une autre
affiche je pense que les gens sont
choqués par plus parce que il s'y
projette que par l'image name même à
l'ère du web 2.0 et des réseaux sociaux
la toile du 19e siècle fait encore
polémique en 2011 des internautes sont
bannis de facebook pour avoir posté une
photo du tableau sur leur compte
une image de nudité contraires au
règlement du réseau social un
utilisateur porte plainte
le fait que finalement facebook n'a pas
fait la différence entre une oeuvre
d'art qui quand même une oeuvre d'art
majeure et de la pornographie ou de la
simple nudité c'est quand même
incroyable
si la justice française reconnaît en
mars 2018 une faute de la part de
facebook
elle déboute le plaignant qui accusait
le réseau social de censure
face à ces décennies de polémique peut
être n'y at il finalement qu'une seule
phrase à retenir celle de gustave
courbet au sujet de son travail il y a
toujours une idée philosophique
humanitaire plus ou moins cachés
à vous de la trouver
[Musique]